يا إلهي ، مقطع فيديو آخر لفيروس كرونوفيرس ،
لا يمكنني تحمله بعد الآن
[موسيقى]
هذا موقف مثير للسخرية ، حيث يصاب
العالم بأسره بالجنون وهذا
ما يبدو عليه ومن المفترض أن
أكون في العمل الآن
كنت أتطلع حقًا
للسفر  العالم مرة أخرى
يصنع أفلامًا لأنني كنت عالقًا في
إجازة الأمومة خلال
الثمانية أو التسعة أشهر الماضية الآن وكنت
أتطلع إلى عدم الاضطرار إلى الطهي
والتنظيف
طوال اليوم ، لقد جعلت حماتي
تنتقل إلى موسكو من
أجل  استبدلي أثناء وجودي في العمل هناك
، والآن بدلاً من السفر حول العالم ،
أنا عالق مع كل شخص في هذه الشقة الصغيرة
هنا ، نحن أسرة سعيدة أيام سعيدة
تساعدني
[موسيقى
] وهذه هي الطريقة التي نقوم بها هذه
الأيام  إذا كنت تتساءل كيف أصور
كل هذا لأنني لن أمتلك
كاميرا
وهذه هي الطريقة التي نجعل بها الأشياء
لأنني لا أملك حتى عصا سيلفي ،
حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، هذا هو كيف تصنع ماما هذه الأفلام
أيام
نعم فكيف حالك التعامل مع
[موسيقى
] اعتقدت
[التطبيق  lause]
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
مرحبًا ستيفان ، مرحبًا بكم ، مرحبًا بك ، مرحباً ،
ربما لم
يعرف جيرانك أنهم  كان هناك مغني أوبرا
يعيش بجانبهم
تمامًا ، ليس لأنني عادةً ما كنت
أكرر
في أه أم في غرفة تعرفها أو في
الأوبرا
أو على خشبة المسرح في باريس ولكن ليس في
مكاني كما تعلم وأنت تعلم أنه يشبه إلى حد كبير
أه
حرفي كما تعلم ، لقد وضعت هاتفي
بهذا الشكل وأنت تعلم أنه على هذا النحو تمامًا
وسأريك أنك تعلم أنك
أخذت معي وأنت تعلم
أن مطبخي هنا مهتز قليلاً
ولكن علينا رؤيتك  امشي هناك ،
هل ما زلت تفعل ذلك كل مساء على
الإطلاق
كل يوم كل يوم أختار آريا مختلفة
فيما يتعلق
بحالة اليوم ، على سبيل المثال ،
غنيت للنيتانيان عندما فقد
الكثير من
الناس رمز هذه النافذة التي تعرفها  أه
في هذا الوقت من
الوحدة  أه يشارك حريته إنه
يعطي بعض المشاعر بعض الفن بعض
كرم التضامن
لأنني في شارعي العديد من
كبار السن أنهم
وحدهم تمامًا
[تصفيق]
انظروا إلى الدعم الذي تحصلون عليه منا يا رفاق
[موسيقى]
هل أنتم اليوم 12 من
الأسبوعين الماضيين يبدو أنه يوم
367 ونصف ،
ما الذي تفعله ، هل ستفعل
[تصفيق]
في آخر 12 يومًا كان مطبخ غرفة النوم
أه الشرفة والظهر وليس
بالضرورة بهذا الترتيب
أو وجدت لحية أرى نعم هذا
صحيح
قليلاً اليوم ، لقد حلقت خدي ، لقد حلقت خدي ،
حسنًا ، لذا تبدو
أنت تبدو أسوأ ،
لقد فقدت بعض الوزن ، وأرى أن معظم
الناس يكتسبون وزنًا ، فأنت تعلم أن ما
لا أملكه كثيرًا
يحدث ، والسبب في ذلك.  الاتصال بك هو لأنني
أريدك أن تساعدني في تجربة هذا الشيء
المسمى البقاء
في شريط المنزل ، لذا عليك الذهاب إلى
ما لا يبقى في لوحة المنزل ،
حسنًا ، أنا انضممت ،
أعتقد أنه هناك
أنا في الداخل
أجنبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هم
[موسيقى]
أنا
[موسيقى  ] هل تشعر بالملل يا حبيبي ، أنا ممل ، أنت ممل ، هل تريد مشاهدة المزيد من مقاطع الفيديو ، نعم ، صفق ، صفق ، صفق ، صفق ، فلنشاهد المزيد من مقاطع الفيديو [موسيقى] [تصفيق] أجنبي صوفيا ، أهلاً [تصفيق] أوه ، لقد زحفت ، بارك الله فيك أنت صغير ، يجب أن يكون ممتعًا حقًا لأن تكون عازبًا الآن ، نعم عندما تكون بمفردك منعزلًا ، لا يوجد أحد يتنقل ويسترخي مع نعم خلايا الواقي الذكري تمر عبر السقف في أماكن مثل الهند ، دعونا نلقي نظرة قد يكون هناك في جميع أنحاء العالم نقص الواقي الذكري حيث تضطر المصانع إلى الإغلاق أثناء جائحة فيروس كورونا ولكن بعد كل هذه العزلة وكل هذا الوقت الجيد يأتي الطلاق لأن الناس لا يستطيعون تحمله ، لذلك ذهب أكثر من 300 شخص وتقدموا بطلب للطلاق ، يقول البعض نعم قد يكون الأمر كذلك سبب ذلك لأن المحاكم تم إغلاقها بمجرد فتح أولئك الذين أرادوا رفع دعوى قبل رفعها ، لكن هناك من يقول إنه كان كل وقت الحجر الصحي الذي يمكنني أن أتخيله حقًا يا طفل رضيع ، صفق صفق صفق صفق
هل تعلم أن عدد حالات
الطلاق يرتفع في الصين
، نعم ، وعدد حالات الطلاق لا
ينبغي أن أتحدث عن الواقي الذكري أمام
طفل ، لكنه لا يستطيع فهم ذلك
.  قلق بشأن
ربما عائلات كبيرة أو عائلات على
أي حال خاصة مع أطفال
يعيشون في شقق صغيرة ، أعتقد أن هذا
يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا
في محطة الفضاء الدولية ،
لدينا محطات فضاء كبيرة لدينا مساحة كبيرة ،
لذا فهذه ليست استراتيجية واحدة صعبة للغاية.
تستخدم أيضًا في محطة الفضاء وهي
إجراء جلسات ملاحظات منتظمة
تعلم أنه يمكنك قول
كل صباح أحد أيام الأحد ، على سبيل المثال ،
سنخبر بعضنا البعض
بشيء جيد أنك تعرف شيئًا ما
تفعله يعجبني حقًا
وربما شيئًا تفعله لا
يعجبني
كثيرًا وربما شخصًا ما يفعل هذا طوال
الوقت ويمكن أن يثير أعصاب شخص ما
ويجب على الجميع أن يقولوا إنه
متساوٍ كما تعلمون
ومن ثم يمكن للجميع بذل جهد
لذا يجب علي
لذلك دعونا نرى كيف يتعامل الآباء الآخرون
مع
الحياة في المنزل مع الأطفال وفي بعض الأحيان أيضًا
تضمين فيروسات العمل
[الموسيقى]
آه ،
نظرت من نافذتي ورأيت هذه الفتاة
ترقص ربما تؤدي أغنية توك التي
كنت بحاجة إليها لأقول لها مرحبًا
نسجت على
شرفتي تلوح للخلف ، أمسكت بقلم الشريط اللاصق
والورق ،
ثم قمت بتدوين أرقامي
وأغلقها على مغازلتي بطائرة بدون طيار عادة ما يكون
أمرًا شاقًا بالنسبة لي ،
لكن منذ أن تم عزلي في
شقتي لمدة أسبوع ، أصبحت الآن
لقد كانت بداية شغف بعض التفاعلات الاجتماعية لعام 2020 سيئة ،
لكنني ما زلت بحاجة إلى التصوير
، التقطت طائرتى بدون طيار وأعتقد أنها
نجحت لأنني تلقيت رسالة منها
بعد ساعة
طلبت منها الخروج لتناول العشاء لكنها قالت
كيف  اضطررت إلى القيام ببعض التفكير ، لكن في البداية
كنت بحاجة إلى الانتعاش ، لذا قمت بحلق
الخيط المصقول وقمت بعدة دفع ،
تم إغلاق محل الحلاقة ، لذا قمت بقص
شعري بعد ذلك ، كان العثور على الملاءمة المثالية ،
حسنًا ، هذه الساعة 5 مساءً.  كان وقت
موعدنا
انتظر أين هو  لقد كانت تمزح فقط ، لقد
اتبعنا القواعد التي لوحظت بها على
الشرفة ، لقد لوحت لها مرة أخرى ،
أخبرتها أنها تبدو جميلة أنك تبدو
جميلًا ، لذا حصلنا على فيس تايم وتناولنا
وجبات العشاء العضوية المطابقة للميكروويف
معًا ،
نسقت بشكل تسلل مع زميل في الغرفة في
وقت سابق لإعداده  كان التاريخ يسير على
ما يرام
اعتمادًا على المدة التي يستمر فيها هذا الحجر الصحي ،
فقد أكون على علاقة طويلة المدى
مع شخص يعيش
عبر الشارع مني ،
حسنًا ، حان الوقت لأجرأ خطوة ، لكنني
آمل ألا تنفجر فقاعاتي التي
احتجت إلى رؤيتها  هي ولكني أردت أيضًا أن
أحترم حقيقة أننا يجب أن
نتباعد اجتماعيًا ، لقد
عبرت الشارع وأرسلت رسالة نصية إلى توري
للخروج والنظر إلى اليسار ،
أعتقد أنها أحببت ذلك ، لقد أحضرت الزهور
ومعقم اليدين ، لكن ذلك كان
خطأً بالنظر إلى أنني كنت مغلقًا  داخل
هذه الفقاعة
[الموسيقى
] بدأ اليوم بقليل من
الذعر
لأننا استيقظنا وأصيب الطفل
بحمى 38.3
اتصلنا بسيارة الإسعاف التي أخبرونا أن
نحصل عليها
لنرى ما إذا كانت ستنجح ،
نأمل أن تتخطى الأصابع أنه
تسنين
ولكن زوجي يعاني الآن من الحمى وأنا
أتحقق من حالتي بينما
نتحدث ومشاهدة الأخبار بالطبع أنت
لست مطمئنًا للغاية بشأن ما
يحدث في جميع أنحاء العالم
ولكننا '  نأمل
أن يكون كل شيء على ما يرام بالطبع نحن
قلقون مثل أي شخص آخر ، حقًا
، هل أنت بخير يا حبيبي ، دعنا نرى ما يحدث ،
نحن رسميًا في حالة إغلاق الأشخاص الذين
قمنا بتخزينهم منذ بضعة أسابيع
لأننا كان لدينا شعور  كان هذا قادمًا من
الضروريات
للطفل وبالطبع مثل باقيكم ،
حصلنا على أرزنا
وبعض المعكرونة الخاصة بأغذية الأطفال ، لذا أعتقد أن هذا يجب أن
يدوم لمدة
شهر جيد ، أعتقد أننا مستعدون
الآن للقاء  أخي
في حال كنت تتساءل عن القفازات
ضرورة هذه
الأيام وهناك أساسي آخر
بالطبع هو القناع هناك ، فلنذهب على
ما يرام ، وآمل ألا تصادف أي
جيران لأنهم سيعتقدون أنني
مريض قليلاً.
كان أخي في المكسيك وعاد
عبر أ  أمستردام ، لقد كان في
عزلة ذاتية
لمدة أسبوعين الآن ولا أعتقد أننا
غير مسؤولين ،
فهو يعيش حرفياً عبر الشارع
مني وسيعمل على أي حال ،
يا روما ، مرحباً ، كيف تسير الأمور كيف كانت
المكسيك ،
لا ينبغي عليّ  اقترب منك بشكل صحيح ،
لا يجب أن تأتي بالقرب منك ، أعتقد أنه
على بعد مترين على الأقل ،
فكيف تشعر بالخارج
آه إنه شعور جيد
أنك تعلم أنه آه تجد أنه مشمس
بالخارج
ولا يمكننا الاستمتاع به لقد شعرت بالدوار
قليلًا في المرة الأولى التي خرجت فيها
لأنني قضيت
14 يومًا في الداخل ، نعم ، لقد كان ذلك فظيعًا نوعًا ما
لم أكن معتادًا على أنه يجب أن أشعر بالرضا
عن الخروج على الرغم من
أنه من الرائع الآن أن أكون بالخارج خاصة
أننا  حصلت على القليل من الشمس اليوم ،
نعم ، لأن الثلج بالأمس ، انظر إلى
ذلك ، نعم ،
ستعمل ، نعم ، سأذهب إلى
العمل.
أستطيع أن أرى أنني حصلت على هذا القناع ،
لدي قفازات
قاموا بتوفير كل هذه الأشياء ،
نعم قناعك  بالتأكيد أفضل من لي ،
نعم ، دعني أرى دعنا نبتعد عني
هناك ، حسنًا ، لكنك
ستذهب إلى العمل كثيرًا على الرغم من
أنه لا يوجد شخص واحد فقط عندما أحتاج
إلى حسن رؤيتك ، يجب أن تكون حريصًا
هناك في العمل.  لا أكون مؤثرًا
وأقول مرحبًا للجميع كما
يفعل الجميع في روسيا ،
آه لا لا قبلاتي لن أقبل أي رجل
اليوم أقسم
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
حسنًا ، لذلك لدينا مقابلة أخرى على سكايب
لتسجيلي لقد طردت عائلتي
إلى  المطبخ بينما أنا متجه
إلى غرفة المعيشة ، بالكاد أستطيع المشي كما
ترون لأنني قمت بنقل
كل شيء بعيدًا عن الطريق ،
فأنا نفد من المواقع في هذا
المصنع ،
إنه مكتظ تمامًا هنا الآن
كما ترون  هذا هو ترايبود المكنسة الصغير الخاص بي.
إلقاء نظرة
على القليل من التذكير بمن هو وكيف
أعرف
حتى تتفهم لماذا أتصل بـ
[موسيقى]
أجنبية ،
أقسم أنه في كل مرة أتحدث معك
يبدو أن الوضع يزداد
سوءًا وأسوأ وأسوأ ،
كنت أفكر في أننا لا ننظر إلا
في
الكوارث لذلك  أخبرني بما يحدث في
اليونان الآن
، لقد استغل الرجل كأنه
غير مؤكد تمامًا أن
جميع الفنادق وشركات المواد الغذائية مغلقة
حتى نهاية أبريل حتى 30
أبريل
مما يعني أنه قد ذهب عيد الفصح الذي يمثل
25 بالمائة من الاقتصاد على الصعيدين الداخلي
والخارجي  أيها السياح ، هذا جنون بالنسبة لنا أه هنا
نكتب لأنفسنا ورقة
يمكنك إما إرسال رسالة أو أه
تنزيل نموذج وملئه أو الحصول على
غناء
مثل قطعة بيضاء فارغة ، نعم
ومنح نفسك إذنًا للخروج ولكن
يمكنك  اذهب إلى السوبر ماركت أو يمكنك
تمشية الكلب
أو تعرف الأشياء الأساسية بالطريقة التي يوجد
بها أشخاص
منذ أن ذكرت الكلاب هناك
أشخاص يتظاهرون بامتلاك كلاب
فقط حتى يتمكنوا من الخروج لمدة 10
دقائق هل فعلت  شاهد أيًا من هؤلاء ،
سأستأجرها إذا كان الجميع مهتمًا ،
مرحبًا ،
مرحبًا ، هذا بيتر ، مرحبا شيرا ، لذا دعني
أريكم بعض مقاطع الفيديو ، دعنا نلقي
نظرة عليها الآن ، وسنعود إلى
المحادثة
[الموسيقى]
عمليا
الناس مجانين  لقد شاهدت مقطع فيديو
لذلك كان مجنونًا وكان
ذلك رجلًا مجنونًا ، فماذا
تفعل الآن ،
أنا أتوقع أه تسمي إلغاء وظيفتها
وهذا هو الرئيسي أه أعباء العمل اليومية الخاصة بي ،
نعم آه وقررت أن
أصبح  Youtuber ،
لذا ، هل ستطبخ لنا
عبر الإنترنت ،
نعم ، إنها قناة متنوعة
أه على أه اليوتيوب تسمى
fuck tv
fahk-tv وهي الأحرف الأولى من اسمي ،
نعم ، سأبدأ بـ uh
10 وصفات  مع بيرة كورونا ، يا
واحدة لطيفة ، أعني
أنني أعتقد أنه كان الشيء الواضح في
البداية ، هل تحققت من أي دورات عبر الإنترنت
للجميع لأنهم يشعرون بالملل من
أدمغتهم ، فهم يجلسون في المنزل
ويحاولون تعلم شيء ما
أو النظر  أنا معجب بكمية
الأشخاص الذين
أعرفهم  لحقيقة لم أكن أعرف كيفية سلق
بيضة
الآن ، فهم يضعونها الآن على Instagram وعلى Facebook
مثل
صور البيتزا ومثل
المعكرونة المصنوعة منزليًا والأشياء ، حسنًا ،
ولكن بجدية ، على الرغم من أنه مثل الآن ،
كيف تخطط للبقاء على قيد الحياة من حيث
الدخل أه  أنا لا أعرف
iiii لم أجرؤ
على التفكير في ذلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
10 نقاط للإبداع هناك يجب أن
أعطيها لهم
نعم أنا أشرب نعم ، أنا
كل شخص في المنزل لديه  تعافى الحمد لله
ولكن الحكومة مددت الآن
إغلاقنا
حتى 30 أبريل ، لذلك
لدينا شهر آخر من هذه
المتعة جيدًا ، ما أفعله الآن
هو الاستماع إلى صديقنا القديم
العزيز ستيفان ،
فلنرى ما يغني لنا
الليلة
[موسيقى]
ابق في المنزل وابحث عن
جيرانك واعلم فقط أن هذا سينتهي
في وقت
ما